welcome to CBS this morning Virginia
Governor Ralph Northam says he is not
going anywhere he plans to stay in
office in spite of a racist photo
printed in his medical school yearbook
in an interview you'll see only on CBS
News we spoke with the Democratic
governor yesterday who still faces calls
to resign he admits to us he struggled
in his initial response to that
photograph on his yearbook page Northam
now says this is a teaching moment for
himself and the country a Washington
Post poll over the weekend shows
Virginians are split on whether he
should stay in office but more than half
of black Virginians do not think that he
needs to step down here's part of our
conversation with the governor what have
you learned that you didn't know before
well several things starting with I was
born in white privilege and that has
implications to it and it is much
different the way a white person such as
myself is treated in this country know
that you were born into white privilege
I knew I was mr. King but I didn't
realize
really the powerful implications of that
and and again talking to a lot of
friends that has come krisily clear to
me this week hi I have also learned why
the use of blackface is so offensive and
yes I knew it in the past but reality
has really said in the governor it's
hard for it's hard for people listening
to you an educated man at the age of 59
to say that you're just learning about
the history of it you didn't know the
history know that it was offensive
before I think we're all on a earning
curve and certainly MS King I'm not the
same person now at age 59 that I was
back in my early 20s but your early 20s
were it was 1984 not 1964 that's right
yes so you would think in 1984 that this
was certainly a problem back then I
don't think there's any question that
there are today and there were then when
I was in my early 20s racial
insensitivity I think there's still
unconscious attitudes that yes we are
aware of these things but we don't
realize sometimes especially as a white
person how impactful how offensive they
are and and again I've still got a lot
to learn but this has been a week
that has been very eye-opening for me
did you have black friends growing up I
did I grew up on the Eastern Shore in a
very rural area when I was in the fifth
grade schools were desegregated so from
the sixth grade through the twelfth
grade I was in integrated schools and
yes I grew up in that environment see
that's that's which makes it even harder
for us to understand you had black
friends or grow up with black people so
it would it would seem that you would be
more sensitive and more aware of that I
don't have any excuses for what I did in
my early life but I can just tell you
that I have learned I have a lot more to
learn I'm a better person and and here
as I said as a 59 year old man governing
the Commonwealth of Virginia this is
really an opportunity I believe to to
make awareness of this issue to to
really have a frank dialogue in
discussion about race and equity in this
country let's go back to the picture and
I know you've addressed it but it still
raises so many questions absolutely
why do you think it came out now I don't
know but this is really the the first
time I have ever seen that picture on
your yearbook page governor well I was
shocked to see it and I really believe
the fact that if you look at the
unpreparedness of me to react to this
both on Friday night and Saturday that
really confirms it that this this is the
first time well let me ask these are
those your pants those pants are very
distinct do you have a pair of pants it
looked like that I have never had any
pants like that you first said that it
was you said you wouldn't say which one
was you that was the first thing and
then you said then you came and
apologized for being in the picture why
would you apologize for something that
horrific if you're not 100% sure that
it's you well I definitely overreacted
and and again but why'd you do that well
when you're in a state of shock like I
was we don't always think as clearly as
as we should I will tell you that later
that night
I had a chance to step back take a deep
breath look at the picture and said this
is not me in the picture and I also had
a number of friends and classmates from
medical school that called and said
Ralph that is not you and and that was
comforting as well furthermore that's a
hell of a overreaction for something
that is so sensitive and so offensive
and so explosive to take responsibility
without really knowing for 100% that
that's me yes again when I when I step
back and looked at it I just said I know
it's not me in the Klan outfit and I
started looking in a picture of the
individual with black face I said that's
not me either and and that's why I felt
so strongly about going in front of the
camera on on Saturday and clarifying
this but instead of clarifying at a
press conference nine days ago he raised
more questions admitting to wearing shoe
polish to darken his face impersonating
Michael Jackson for a dance competition
that's right are you still able to
moonwalk my wife says in appropriate
circumstances for many of us watching it
looked like you were about to actually
demonstrate the moonwalk were you
thinking about showing off your
moonwalking skills no because I don't
have those at age 59 but I will tell you
again I regret that this is a serious
moment very soon and whether it was a
nervous laugh or whatever it was
inappropriate
so you weren't thinking about doing it
when you looked over at that the floor
you were not thinking about doing a
moonwalk no many people credit pam-pam
your lovely wife or stepping into them
another reason to be nicer on
valentine's day for you sir
jo let me just tell you that as we say
i'm married way up and i would not be
sitting here having this conversation if
it wasn't for my my wife of 33 years
what do you say to people that are
looking at this story if you do stay in
office which you say you are someone
that commits a racist offense and says
well the governor did it
he and he's okay do you think it sends a
message that that this isn't being taken
seriously if you stay in office when so
many people that the highest levels want
you to step down you know I'm not here
to make any excuses but I will tell you
that the man that you're looking at
right now at at age 59 who has given
over 35 years of service to the United
States Army I have taken care of
thousands of sick children and have had
over 12 years of public service to the
Commonwealth of Virginia the man you're
looking at and talking to right now is
not who I was in my early 20s I have
learned I admit to my mistakes and I'm
going to improve my life and do better
and be in a position where I can help
other people that's why I do what I do
Gayle every morning I get up if I feel
like I'm helping people then that makes
me content it's a very interesting time
for the governor because what what I
walked away feeling is that he so wants
to make this right and I talked to many
black people and white people in
Virginia who say he has a lot of support
in the state of Virginia we say give
look at his history look what he's done
no one the people I talked to do not
believe that he's racist they think that
it was a stupid thing but they do not
think that he's a racist well it was
such a good interview and I think what
she did it was trying broaden the lens
yes give us more context behind when we
judge people very quickly and give a
larger scope of this his career includes
working as a pediatric neurologist
taking go visiting the homes of hundreds
of African American families in crisis
he went to an integrated school his
parents could have sent him to a private
all-white school as the New York Times
points out today we have to view this in
context and what we can learn from it
yeah missteps but it's not an
interesting article over the weekend
guys were it said is there anybody out
there that can't say they did something
stupid in their 20s or in their 30s well
men that has any question will be to
take the experience from the past when
he's going through now and bring it to
the present when he talks about
unconscious attitudes of today yes what
is he identifying and what light does he
shine on those and new understanding
does he show that's in the moment now
that's not about something that happen
in the past
and so that's what lays before him he
was quite vague but what he brings
forward and what everybody sees from
this about what goes on today and what's
unconscious today is really interesting
and what resonated with him saying
multiple times no excuses right here
that last Friday no he's not trying to
explain it and he has some explaining to
do I asked about the shoe polish comment
you know there's still more to come when
talking to the governor we'll hear more
of that variable